10 après le bio et les produits light la
suite celui de notre série sur les
habitudes alimentaires on va parler du
snacking
autrement dit manger sur le pouce alors
c'est pratique et dans ce domaine les
industriels ont fait des progrès pour
répondre à la demande des consommateurs
qui exigent des produits plus varié plus
sain et en même temps qu'ils ont du goût
l'enquète d'alice gauvin et xavier roman
c'est la bête noire des nutritionnistes
le snacking
autrement dit le fait de manger sur le
pouce à la place d'un repas complet ou à
n'importe quel moment de la journée
une variante du grignotage une évolution
sociologique aussi il ya plus de gens
qui travaillent mais il ya aussi une
volonté d'avoir plus de temps pour soi
et on voit maintenant de plus en plus de
personnes qui font leurs courses tout en
mangeant un sandwich ou qui vont aller
se promener ou faire différentes
activités et en n'ayant plus vraiment le
repas comme un moment où on est à table
et qu'on consomme un vrai un vrai ou pas
mais à l'heure du déjeuner le
travailleur tressé délaissent de plus en
plus le sandwich et le hamburger au
profit une formule plus diversifiée ici
les pâtes à emporter
c'est agréable c'est bon et ce mois
c'est moins grave ventes est moins lourd
si on s'attarde pas plutôt équilibré et
rapidement servi
c'est une bonne solution une oie les
sushis comme c'est une cuisine japonaise
en tout cas c'est
las équilibré à cette éthique est bon
pour la santé sont en lancement
d'aujourd'hui de loire s'alimenter
sainement de suivre les prescriptions
des pouvoirs publics vis-à-vis d'une
alimentation saine et cinq fruits et
légumes par jour
évitez de manger trop sucré trop salé
trop gras c'est quelque chose qui fait
vraiment son chemin dans l'esprit des
français en tête des produits consommés
par les snacks heures les fruits frais
le snack cherche à se défaire de sa
mauvaise image du tri sionnel avec de
nouveaux produits salade laitages ou
légumes déjà découpé sain et pratique
c'est aujourd'hui le credo du snack
heures autre lieu autre ambiance
dans ce grand magasin on a inventé le
snack tris chic gourmand et gourmet de
la foulée carottes avec une avec moi que
tu bois avec plus de ce genre des pentes
d'aspen et la sauce qui est toujours à
l'écart les recettes sont dignes d'un
grand restaurant et pour cause salades
et sandwiches sont élaborées sous la
direction d'alain ducasse
ils ont essayé de faire descendre la
gastronomie dans leur rue comédie comme
dit monsieur ducasse c'est à dire que la
bonne les bonnes choses puissent être
offerte à tous le sort de toutes les
sortes de public qu'il soit chic léger
au plus gras le snacking a de beaux
jours devant lui
selon un sondage ipsos 92% des français
snack régulièrement